hello and welcome back to steampunks
GameSpot's premiere show about the only
show about PC gaming specifically we
talk about issues like the PC game is
what people are worrying about and all
that kind of stuff now we've taken a
little bit of a break and we've been a
bit traitorous because we've been
playing again that's not on PC yeah and
that is a Red Dead Redemption - yeah I
think if you like games you know you're
going to be paying attention to this
particular Rockstar title and being like
I gotta play that it's the game of the
generation why isn't it on PC
yeah so we're gonna kind of try to
address some of the reasons why that
happens in white games like great games
that come to PC yeah but also gonna talk
about well it's a messaging I mean Red
Dead in particular like anyone who has
had a conversation with new Red Dead
knows I have continually complained
about the fact that the first game never
came to BC in fact that is the reason
that I missed out on playing it but I'm
really enjoying the second game and I'm
holding out hope that given that
Rockstar bought GTA 5 to PC hopefully we
can expect the same for Red Dead
Redemption too sometime in the year to
come I have some strong stuff still
don't seem to be doing you any harm I
guess this might seem obvious to a lot
of people but when I used to work in a
video game store people would come up to
me all the time like oh adults children
of all ages and speed like why can't
they marry on PlayStation right it's not
obvious a lot of people that don't
aren't keyed into the business aspect of
games and all the technological side
which is kind of what you touched on and
that's you know one of the main things
is there is a technical hurdle sometimes
when you develop games specifically for
a proprietary console like a Playstation
or Nintendo and bring that to BC can be
a lot of work and a lot of time and
money which is why a lot of games don't
make it but in the case of GTA 5
obviously that started on a Playstation
3 and Xbox 360 and then they spend a lot
of money putting it to PlayStation 4 and
Xbox one yeah and then eventually that
meant it could get a PC
and because they migrated all that all
that kind of code and graphics and
textures onto a platform that could be
read by the new generation of consoles
all of which are very similar in
architecture you know the possibility is
there for Red Dead Redemption to to come
to on PC like it's just a matter of when
and obviously the other issue of
capitalism and like business and like
exclusivity and the deals that go behind
closed doors about the business of
selling games yeah so that's when you
get your certainty exclusives your Xbox
exclusive that isn't really something
that the PC will deals with you don't
know you really get pieces you get games
that really only makes sense on PC and
that's why they tend to come out on PC I
really do support multi-platform as we
talked about on this show on a different
episode but I think what's what's really
fantastic now is for example Xbox of
course Microsoft are excellent I'm PC
but then coming out and saying look all
of a major like all our first party
stuff will be coming Julie to Xbox one
and it will be coming to PC and I would
love to see more of that yeah cuz it's
so easy for them yeah obviously
Sony and Microsoft do have a vested
interest in selling these proprietary
consoles to people who don't already
have them obviously PCs are everywhere
you know like you use a computer for
your everyday tasks and yeah you could
probably play ready tension on it
eventually if it's not awful enough that
we're assuming that they're cutting
deals with companies like Rockstar to be
like hey we know your game is gonna be
friggin huge we will give you a share of
our profits if you bring your game to
our consoles exclusively for a period of
time so we can sell a bunch of units and
everyone who wants to play red did you
can do so on a Playstation or an Xbox in
case of Red Dead 2 it's specifically a
PlayStation because there there's that
exclusive content that you can get if
you buy it on PlayStation but yeah I
think the important thing to realize
about exclusivity deals is that they
they won't last forever you know it's
like you know I really want to play GTA
5 on PC but you know I bought it on ps3
played through it and when they
announced the ps4 version about a year
later I bought it again and played
through it because it's a game that I
really loved and I want to play through
multiple times and when it comes out
when GTA 5 came out on PC I bought it
again
cuz I was like mods and stuff it's gonna
be that's my running theory with why Red
Dead Redemption isn't on pc yet i reckon
they're gonna wait for just the right
amount of time that people who picked it
up and do have consoles and loved it on
console are willing to buy it again
you're amazing i think it's gonna be
just enough time that people like i'll
get that up yes and obviously that helps
sony NEX box massively in terms of
profit and revenue then it really helps
Rockstar to because people will buy this
game all the items and you know which is
weird to say been only a company like
Rockstar who makes massive games that
everyone wants to play like this is the
probably the one game people some people
will buy for like years and years yeah
they have the power to do that which is
kind of a little consumer unfriendly
yeah in like a proper like that's
exploitative way but also like you know
I like to revisit games every few years
or so having a better version of that is
on PC is you know that's I'll buy it
I'll play it again
yeah Arthur oh sorry that was miles away
well jumping off from the slight
disappointment and those of you who do
only play on PC having to wait and cross
your fingers to wait for Red Dead roots
and to to possibly arrive
we thought we'd also chat about a couple
of games that we wish came to pay say
yeah that probably will never but I wish
they did I think my first one is persona
5 I always know the games that I wish
would come to PC because they're the
games that persona 5 was my game of the
year when it came out and the games that
I tell my dad who's a PC game I
exclusively oh you should really play
this game oh wait you call it so it's
it's weird because my pics are Japanese
games as well I think Japanese games
have traditionally like never really
been a PC market it's all like maybe you
like this decade maybe and even then
they're still primarily a console nation
yeah and so a lot of really great
console games would come out of Japan
are made for your Playstations and even
tendo's and they don't have any desire
to port them to PC although that is
changing with a lot of companies like
Capcom especially bring DMC and Resident
Evil's to PC because they know the West
really really loves their games there
for something like persona
it's like a japanese-style abbaji it's
Japanese as hell right yeah and they
just I like people want to play this
they are gonna own a Playstation anyway
they will like JRPGs and they will have
a playstation to play them on it just
seems like it's such a market I think
that was really my point with I wish
persona 5 will come because it's filling
a nation I don't think is really all the
way there on PC and it would be such
like a it's a good bridge in game 2 for
people who don't necessarily find
themselves already deep in the JRPG
genre yeah and just the fact that it's
turn-based I mean like it's a fantastic
genre for PC it's a fantastic giant
world I am one of those people who is
very happy to play a hundred-plus alle
game sitting at my PC as well yeah yeah
PC game is like RPGs and I think
obviously you want more Jabbar users
come TBC people someone needs someone
like Atlas they need to take no risk and
try and put it and see you know how
that's going
so like ninokuni 2 from Namco Bandai
came to PC very recently and I think
that's doing pretty well and that's like
one of the premier JRPGs this year so I
had a couple of games in mind in terms
of console games that I really want to
come to PC one of them is like gonna be
impossible and that's like Super Mario
Galaxy anything Nintendo because you
know they're fantastic platform is you
know and I would love to play something
that came out on the Wii in sort of an
SDS I said a definition format and be
able to play on a sort of timeless
platform how'd it be upscaled and sort
of like the crisp and sharp and so gonna
enjoy all the textures and sort of the
animations that they put into that game
and you know it's a fantastic
platforming game that I want to play
again and again that will never happen
because the Nintendo is very closed off
in their sort of dev environment and
obviously they want to sell a lot of
Nintendo consoles which is fair
which is why they release things again
and again but the one that I think is
slightly more realistic is the Metal
Gear Solid series so it's gonna get
solid one two three four specifically
since five and ground zeroes did make it
to PC and they're great port Merida
solid wanted to did come to PC a long
time ago but their port though this was
back in the era where PC ports were
really shoddy they're really bad really
poor they're missing like textures are
missing animations and cutscenes and so
I would love for a proper
Metal Gear Solid HD remake maybe say
between snakes or like the HD collection
of two and three that came out on the
ps3 and ps4 and leader to make their way
over to PC and I have them just so I can
have it prefer like my own sort of
archive and be able to play these like
classic games that I really love in a
pristine format yeah
that's slightly more realistic but also
not because Konami has really poor
priorities right now and the games are
really old and would take a lot of work
that I'm not sure they're willing to
invest in yeah I mean Nelly usually wait
exclusives I think like I think everyone
probably would agree just like those
there's bucket of fantastic certainly
exclusives yet PC players I'm missing
out on the spider-man's the uncharted
horizons like fantastic beautiful games
that would look incredible on a PC with
a decent graphics card that because of
the business side of it just won't make
it yeah looks like they they have a
bazillion Sony PlayStation's out in the
world and they're not gonna let go this
is why they were so like had such a
tight grip on cosplay yeah you never
know things could change like the future
is still to come and you know we could
all just have one PC platform in the
future who knows that is just what we
think there's there let us know down in
that comment section what console game
you wish would come to PC and if you
reckon that Red Dead Redemption 2 is
gonna make its way over I think it will
I think we should ask when okay when I
would say one year I think one and a
half years 9 months place your bets let
us know in the comment section and we'll
be back with a new episode next week
[Music]
you